we have a voicemail number the numbers
two one nine two david p we heard from
this is the Eggman today right this is a
from let's take a listen to what the
Eggman had to say hi Dave
I feel like FBI director James Comey and
Vice President Mike Pence are involved
in the conspiracy to make Mike Pence
president Comey is just saying to pence
on their secret burner phone just a
little bit longer Mike just a little bit
longer Mike and I'll get you there I
told you Mike play the long game and
you've got it yeah listen it's it's a
nice little hypothesis that the egg man
has cooked up there for for us my sort
of concern about whether this is this is
what's going on it would be not that
there might not be something like this
going on but that if Donald Trump is
revealed to have come to power based on
collusion with Russia its Trump pence
right I don't know I don't know that
pence would be exempt from what whatever
is determined as having happened with
Trump and Russia it would have been to
get the Trump pence ticket in the White
House so I don't necessarily believe
that pence would be immune from the
repercussions I think you would need to
find evidence that pence was involved
though and also I think he only joined
the Trump campaign in July so maybe
there was less influence there yeah less
less but not none I think that that's
pretty clear I really wonder how pence
is feeling right now though is he
excited he could become the next
president pretty easily if maybe Paul
Ryan is the one who's excited about
being the next president of the United
States
I don't know but interesting hypothesis
from the eggman on the bonus show today
Sesame Street is introducing a muppet
with autism we will talk about that
basketball player Shaquille O'Neal
apparently believes the earth is flat
and Boston a particular school here in
Boston has changed the world map that
they're now using in geography classes
it's confusing to some students but it's
actually a really really interesting
topic that I have some thoughts on and I
want to dig into on the bonus show so
we've got a great bonus show planned for
you today david pakman.com slash
membership to sign up coupon code I
voted 17 is available we will speak to
you on the bonus show